buonasera a tutti è un'emozione vedere
tante persone dal vivo per me che è
parte della mia vita la dedico agli
eventi e ritornare a vivere le emozioni
dal vivo è una grande cosa ma oggi non
parlerò di eventi non però di emozioni
ma prodi arte e cercherò di delineare
quelle che sono le dieci regole
dell'identità al size questo è un
progetto editoriale nato molti anni fa
dati in maniera anonima e o addirittura
non firmava ho cominciato con le pagine
di wikipedia è poi data si è voluto sui
social quindi un progetto nato dal basso
e poi diventato una serie di libri che
sto pubblicando congiunti
proprio per rivalutare gli artisti
dimenticati del novecento quindi che non
ce l'hanno fatta quelli che sono stati i
famosi poi sono caduti nell'ombra quelli
che la vita ha preso a calci quelli che
hanno avuto mille difficoltà ad
affrontare questo percorso in qualche
modo era però necessario per me da
affrontare tornando nel passato perché
si fa sempre i conti col passato e
quando ero un bambino aveva una grande
passione che era giocare a calcio avevo
la passione delle figurine panini
avevo la passione di legge mi piaceva
pinocchio e poi a un certo punto vivi
per terra dei biglietti del cinema
qualcuno li ha gettati lì saranno
bellissime come la possibile gettare via
una cosa così bella e quindi di raccolti
comincia a collezionare le cose gettate
per terra i biglietti del teatro i
biglietti del cinema fino alle tazzine
di birra che la negazione del
collezionismo perché è impossibile
finire una collezione fatta di oggetti
che non hanno fine ma soprattutto
significa dare valore a qualcosa che gli
altri gettano via e poi una volta mi
capitò una fotografia quelle che gli
americani chiamano snap shot cioè le
foto scattate le foto vecchie quelle che
compri per pochi euro per pochi
centesimi sulle bancherelle io adoro
vedere questi volti accigliati questi
ritratti di famiglie vecchi una bombetta
quello che però mi colpisce di queste
foto è che se li osservo bene pensano
che forse sono tutti morti e che forse
solo io possiedo quella fotografia e
quindi avere quella fotografia significa
in qualche modo mantenerli in vita e
quindi mi piace quando li guardano
dritti negli occhi io cerco di capire
che cosa hanno fatto qualche cosa
successe delle loro vite
qui ho cominciato a pormi delle domande
sulle cose che vedevo guardate questa
foto questa foto l'ho trovata su un
banco credo che va pagato due euro ed è
un uomo e una donna
io all'inizio pensavo sinceramente che
era un uomo e una bambina
immaginavo il padre della figlia però
lei è strana perché lei è in mano una
fotografia con dei numeri di un
calendario e qualcuno mi ha fatto notare
che potrebbe sembrare un vestito
premaman quindi potrebbe essere un uomo
e all'epoca forse questa è una foto
degli anni trenta come moglie
giovanissima che incinta e tiene la foto
e la madre la madre che lontana qual è
il segreto dietro a questa foto è che io
non ho mai avuto la soluzione a queste
righe ma ho capito che bisogna
cominciare a porsi delle domande anche
andare al di là di ciò che si vede
abitualmente
prendete una grande capolavoro del
novecento una delle icone
secondo me il robot di metropolis è una
delle grandi icone del 1900 mah io
chiedessi a voi chi ha disegnato il
robot maria nessuno deve lo saprebbe
così come non sapevo io mi sono dato a
documentarmi ho scoperto che c'è un
personaggio che si chiama otto punte the
production design del film e così
abbiamo sempre ignorato così come
abbiamo ignorato quelli che sono gli
altri collaboratori che hanno costruito
questo immaginario straordinario che per
esempio poi ha generato blade runner è
parte della nostra identità
eppure sono dei semplici come diciamo
noi
scenografie non sono gli artisti
importanti e quindi ho capito una cosa
fondamentale che è la prima legge
dell'identità outsiders nella creatività
non esiste una differenza tra alto e
basso dimenticatela è una cosa che ci
hanno imposto
la qualità quando la vedi la riconosci
subito e della qualità di un pancake e
la qualità di una ripresa televisiva e
la qualità di un elemento di design
guardate questo oggetto io direi subito
un donatello
io oggi sono andato via clavature a
vedere niccolò dell'arca il compianto di
cristo se non ci siete andati andateci
perché è uno dei capolavori dell'arte
mondiale
eppure questo non è altro che un
manichino utilizzato negli anni 40 negli
stati uniti per provare la tenuta dei
paracaduti ma la bellezza di quest'opera
è pari a quella di una grande opera di
qualunque altro artista
guardate queste immagini sulla sinistra
c'è spadolini che era un danzatore primo
danzatore che ha danzato nudo era di
riccio nando a parigi ed è stato un
grande amore con e di piazza mentre
sulla destra è una foto di più bricca
alla kubica è famoso per il film ma
questa volta è straordinaria quindi
questi dire che questa foto è meno
importante della foto di del cinema di
kubrick e non credo
così come è importante 300 è un oggetto
iconico della nostra epoca così come un
oggetto di design quello che hanno fatto
behrens nelle fabbriche e gay trovando
dei nuovi modi di interpretare l'utilità
sugli oggetti o la scultura di uno
scrittore sia un altro week che tanti
esperti d'arte conosco perché forse la
mars la massa conosce meno anche uno dei
grandi scultori del novecento oppure
andare nei musei vedere le opere meno
importanti quella di sinistra è un
ritratto multiplo di cesare sofianopulo
che ho voluto come copertina del secondo
libro out sider 2 che io trovo
straordinario che in qualche modo già
presagisce il volto tetro vide gioca al
centro vedete il casco fatto da uno del
lavoratore delle piattaforme petrolifere
nell'oceano pacifico che passano il
tempo intagliano il proprio casco per
fare un oggetto d'arte di cui è nato un
collezionismo e con la destra invece
sono i progetti di chiattone un
architetto straordinario che condivise
con sant'elia lo studio e poi ha voluto
fare una vita diversa
una vita in qualche modo basata sulla
borghesia data fare di svizzera il
benestante ho capito quindi che l'arte è
connessa la vita che questa è la seconda
legge degli orsaia se l'ho capito anche
dell'esperienza che ha avuto con mio
padre mio padre un pittore era un
artista è stato un teorico
dell'educazione artisti che ha fatto
tante trasmissioni televisive come non è
mai troppo tardi e telescuola lui era
allievo di casorati e passò dal
figurativo all'astratto
e questo è lo studio mio padre era
figlio di contadini e lui era abituato a
pensare che i figli dovessero aiutare il
padre quindi di riprenderla mi portava
studio e io dovevo passare a sistemare
le tele esposte le sculture da destra a
sinistra da sinistra a destra
però questa esperienza mi ha permesso di
capire che le cose che lui creava
avevano dei significati per lui l'arte
non è disgiunta dalla vita e che forse
noi continuiamo a guardare solamente
l'aspetto esteriore delle opere mentre
forse dovremmo porci delle domande e
quindi questa esperienza mi ha fatto
capire che ogni opera aveva un
significato e che forse non siamo più
abituati a capire perché non ci poniamo
più delle domande e quindi abbiamo alla
terza legge dell'identità outsiders la
vita è una variabile impazzita
prendete il 1900 è stato un secolo
spaventoso ci sono stati 82 conflitti
se parlando di 130 milioni morti ci sono
state 80 milioni di morti trager usciti
e persecuzioni un cittadino europeo su
tre ha avuto problemi da un punto vista
politico ha subito delle discriminazioni
e poi sono state le epidemie sono stati
50 100 milioni di morti di epidemia per
la febbre spagnola e su questi grandi
problemi del novecento si sono innescate
i problemi individuali di ognuno di noi
la condizione femminile essere donna per
un artista sempre stata una sciagura
addirittura agli artisti out sider
veniva negato il fatto che le donne
potessero produrre
l'orientamento sessuale la
discriminazione di chi aveva degli
interessi sessuali diversi dalla massa
la povertà la disabilità e infine
l'autodistruzione cioè la voglia di
distruggersi guardate di nuovo via
clavature che sembra un po il centro del
mondo fate cento passi via clavature 20
c'era tra un fabric che era questo luogo
di una casa occupata dove negli anni
settanta tamburini e pazienza hanno
comunque costruito un immaginario
straordinario però se non hai e della
distruzione utilizzando la droga che è
stato l'ennesimo flagello della
generazione degli anni 70 80 90 eroina e
poi la droga si è cambiata ed è cambiato
anche il tempo e la quarta legge di al
sadr ci dice anche una cosa importante
che sia se ne sono dimenticati e chi si
dimentica e sempre in colpa come diceva
energia chi dimentica non ama prende
dell'arte degenerata voi sapete che
hitler scatena una guerra contro l'arte
moderna considerato la degenerata e
quindi fece una mostra che ne prendeva
in bolletta e fece bruciare le opere
perseguito gli artisti e noi sappiamo i
nomi degli artisti molti riconoscono
croft orient paul klee
quello che però interessante che quando
prendi il catalogo di questa mostra
scopri che erano decine se non centinaia
gli artisti degenerati erano stati
individuati di questi personaggi
paul casseur nessuno sa niente di molte
di loro non si ha idea neanche la data
di morte perché anche fra i diseredati
ci sono quelli di seriale con le di
serie b e addirittura c'era un
personaggio di sacal slicing che era un
pittore espressionista e quindi
degenerato comunista e nano quindi era
degenerato tre volte e quando poi finì
la guerra e lui pensava di poter essere
aiutato dal governo scoprire di non
essere abbastanza famoso per essere
aiutato
il governo e quindi ebbe una profonda
crisi depressiva e poi morì tragicamente
vediamo la quinta legge degli outsiders
gassate sono dei perdenti di talenti
sono perdenti di definizione non
scelgono mai luoghi e le date giuste per
nascere creare amare morire vivono in
mondi paralleli e hanno sempre
l'indirizzo sbagliato
prendete l'arte americana la grande arte
americana
basta leggere i nomi accorgersi che sono
realtà di derivazione diversa mark
rothko viene della lettonia e aveva uno
pseudonimo
mark rothko as a gorki veniva d'allarme
della madre è morta di fame passando in
un barcone in fuga dal genocidio degli
armeni in grecia è lo stesso andy warhol
e la di famiglia ucraina ma loro
sarebbero diventati così famosi nel loro
paese
e parliamo la stessa legge degli
outsiders saranno perdenti ma sono
sempre andati contro o verso qualcosa e
sono i grandi dimenticati protagonisti
del nostro tempo
prendete questo quadro questo e 1900 di
riuscire abbiamo studiato tutti è il
primo quadro astratto un acquerello di
kandisky ebbene quattro anni prima
questa donna che sembra uscita da un
romanzo dell'ottocento che si chiamava
kill fa clint vedesse alto un metro e
cinquanta piccola facendo telesur e
spiriti che incomincia a costruire dei
quadri straordinari che sono dei quadri
astratti e guardate le dimensioni fa dei
quali grandissimi giganteschi ma nessuno
li vede in vita e quando li muore lascia
detto che nessuno li può vedere per
trent'anni dopo la morte rimangano
ancora dentro delle casse sono stati
praticamente riscoperti negli ultimi 20
anni e quest'anno il guggenheim ha fatto
una mostra dedicata ai fan clean che
porterà riscrivere un po la storia
dell'arte così come nessuno metterebbe
nei dieci quadri più famosi della sua
dell'arte il quadrato nero di mare
rischia un quadro fondamentale dell'arte
contemporanea che lo stesso male che ci
vuole porre nel proprio letto di morte
guardando quel quadro che era in qualche
modo il sesso estremo il punto di
partenza dell'arte astratta
eppure di nuovo questo nei libri di
storia dell'arte abituali leggiamo e poi
sono tanti prendete parigi parigi inizio
del novecento
l'esposizione universale ed erano 80
mila gli artisti c'erano 80 mila artisti
quanto varese una città gli artisti ma
quanti ne conosciamo
facendo un'analisi veramente prendete i
dati da amazon a occhio il 90 per cento
delle monografie sull'arte del novecento
parla di 59 artisti di 12 nazioni 59 su
80mila che solo in quel periodo nella
parigi è di nuovo vi dico il segreto
della mostra perfetta la mostra perfetta
è da caravaggio modigliani passando per
la ngog
ormai noi viviamo su questi elementi di
questi titoli di questi nomi e di nuovo
ci dimentichiamo che questi tre
personaggi hanno sofferto nella vita
sapete tutti di van gogh di modigliani
ma forse lo sapete che lo stesso
caravaggio
fino agli anni 20 era dimenticato è
stato uno scrittore italiano e critico
roberto longhi a rilanciare la figura di
caravaggio che era uno dei mille pittori
del seicento quello che facciamo è un
effetto marmellata
e l'invito che io vi faccio questa sera
e di ricominciare a vedere con occhi
nuovi il mondo dell'arte e mondo degli
outsiders per esempio provando
immaginare formati diversi per le mostre
forma diversi per le esposizioni museali
e allora se devo smettere di fare una
cosa terrificante e andare a vedere nei
musei di targhette prima si guarda la
targhetta poi si guarda l'opera d'arte
ritornate a usare gli occhi fatevi delle
domande sulle cose che vedete qual è la
storia dietro a quel quadro e guardatevi
solo il quadro
guardatevi solo l'opera che c'è dentro
potrete scoprire opere straordinarie che
nessuno conosce pro serie di velasco
l'ho trovato in una sala laterale calma
caffè
un pittore russo è stato trovato dai
collezionisti buttato nel mercato delle
pulci perché tutto il suo archivio era
stato buttato e venduto per pochi euro
ci sono scortese c'è un calciatore della
juventus che è diventato pittore la
blanchard mari blanchard una disabile è
una grandissima per trichet cubista in
qualche modo non valorizzata come
dovrebbe e mettere sullo stesso piano
cose diverse
la cultura della controcultura che
ricerca l'ambra però per cambia o anche
il pulcino elefante c'è una piccola casa
editrice che pubblica libri deliziosi in
pochissime copie e questo ci porta all
ottava legge negli all sider che hanno
storie straordinarie che aspettano solo
di essere raccontate come filonov morto
di fame durante la sede di essere in
grado perché non vuole vendere un solo
quadro perché voleva lasciare la sua
opera a tutti voi e voleva che un museo
la prendesse la conservasse o al
contrario una donna a roma così povera
che dopo aver dipinto dei quali
straordinari vestiva da uomo era un
personaggio stravagante e morte non si
sa la sua data di morte il suo corpo è
stato buttato nelle pop nella fosse di
pubblica pietà ma ci sono anche i ricchi
tomaso buzzi così ricco da guadagnare
facendo le ville dei ricchi e poi con i
soldi guadagnati costruire la scarzuola
che uno dei più bei luoghi a
montegabbione una delle città utopica a
cui vi invito di andare a fare una
visita in questo autunno general murphy
miliardario che in tre anni solo dopo
aver inventato i bagni di mare a saint
tropez costruisce delle opere
straordinarie che presagiscono la pop
art e di cui anche io non avevo mai
sentito parlare che ho scoperto per caso
come oro e cura anche questo mai parlato
e da nessuno e mi ha raccontato a
nessuno in italia un monaco giapponese
che deve diventare monaco di un tempio
che scopre l'arte occidentale andando a
ruba le riviste del trasporto queste
storie vedete sono diverse come si come
relatori che si sono ripetuti in questo
luogo c'è un indiana
c'è una
cinese pyol anche una bambina venduta
che ha cominciato a fare la prostituta e
che tramite l'arte ha trovato in qualche
modo la propria identità
jorge se la donna che ha costruito la
scala a rio simbolo di riavere un cileno
ed è morto su questa scala forse ucciso
da una banda rivale taglia terranno i
fratelli italiani che hanno aumentato la
tuta che sono in qualche modo gli ultimi
geni del rinascimento la baronessa elsa
phone friday loringhoven a cui gli
champs e rubò l'orinatoio di fila di cat
un genio vissuto in 40 metri quadri per
una malattia che si ma l'attesa dello
girati fallo che si chiama con le mani a
barchetta che rappresenta se stesso in
maniera ironica e piena di poesia e
questo sono la nona legge degli insiders
non sono soltanto quelli che ci sono
state rialzate sono tra noi e si
riproducono sono accanto a voi non
dobbiamo aspettare che bangkok a perdere
orecchio riattacchiamo l'orecchio a van
gogh e ognuno shueisha alzate
diminuzione del se sono loro sono fausto
delle chiaie che ogni giorno dietro
l'ara pacis a roma mette una mostra dei
soggetti concettuali e mauro gottardo
che è un giovanissimo
autore calligrafo che sui lunghi fogli
di carta con la penna biro realizza dei
passaggi straordinarie e mario pischedda
e addirittura dedicato un sito d'amore a
mario pescato io sono pazzo di barbie
scheda che un fotografo che vive in un
piccolo luogo della gallura e che
produce maniera bulimica su facebook
ogni giorno una galleria d'arte di video
performance convinto che l'arte deve
essere in qualche modo regalata
dove sono i vostri cercateli sono qua
nel palazzo accanto forse a via
clavature che cito per la terza volta al
terzo piano c'è qualcuno che fa qualcosa
e questo ci introduce anche all'ultima
delle leggi con cui chiudo gli outsiders
non fanno gli outsiders per moda non
sono lì a giocare a fare gli outsiders
per cui se amate l'arte dovete fare solo
una cosa compratela investire in bello
investite nel bello di tutti i giorni
perché non c'è nulla di più inutile
nell'arte del sider non hanno voglia di
morire non amano morire non vogliono
essere dei martiri perché la vita
importante e c'è solo una cosa
importante oltre la vita che la morte ci
trovi vivi come diceva marcello marchesi
[Applauso]